der bundestag debattiert hier die ganze
woche über die vorhaben der
ampelkoalition das ganze nennt sich
vereinbarte debatte zur politik der
bundesregierung und es geht von einem
ressort zum nächsten und deswegen höre
können jetzt hier sozusagen die
fachpolitiker ein bisschen in den reihen
hin und her auch der bundestags
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki bittet
auch noch mal die platzwechsel zügig
vorzunehmen
denn jetzt kommen die fachpolitiker für
ernährung landwirtschaft sozusagen die
vorderen reihen denn dieses ressort
steht jetzt an der neue minister cem
özdemir für ernährung und landwirtschaft
hier sehen sie ihn schon auf der
regierungsbank der will nichts weniger
als eine neue ausrichtung der
agrarpolitik und die ampel parteien
wollten schon in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
ein zeichen in richtung veränderung der
landwirtschaft senden dazu werden wir
einiges hören beispielsweise
der ökolandbau bis zum jahr 2030 soll
dieser ein anteil von 30 prozent haben
derzeit sind es noch 15 prozent aber es
steht noch einiges mehr an vorhaben im
koalitionsvertrag zu diesem ressort
jetzt hören wir den minister
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
am letzten sonntag erzählt die
frankfurter allgemeine sonntagszeitung
fas zwei seiten platz genommen um sich
mit der situation von landwirtinnen und
landwirte in der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu beschäftigen
ich kann allen nur die lektüre dieses
artikels ans herz legen der titel lautet
der landwirt am limit und damit es
eigentlich schon alles gesagt er
berichtet von dem enormen druck dem land
wird er ausgeliefert sind ökonomisch
physisch aber vor allem auch psychisch
harte arbeit sorgen ums einkommen sogar
anfeindungen stand anerkennung meine
damen und herren es geht hier um die
menschen die dafür sorgen dass wir
täglich und sein essen auf dem tisch
haben da darf man gerne auch mal danke
dazu sagen
unsere landwirtschaft geht uns alle an
wir alle jede und jeder einzelne von uns
profitiert von der großartigen
leistungen die auf unseren höfen bewacht
wird wir alle leben im wahrsten sinne
des wortes davon und da wir alle
betroffen sind wird es natürlich auch
schnell mal persönlich emotional und
nicht selten auch holzschnittartig ich
habe das ja jetzt auch als reaktion auf
die ersten äußerungen schon mitbekommen
ich freue mich auf die debatte denn wenn
man sie ernsthaft führen dann trägt sie
vielleicht auch dazu bei uns die
leistungen der landwirtschaft ins
bewusstsein zu rufen wir müssen
weiterkommen dazu erst gut wenn man die
aufregung des ökonomie einfach mal
hinter uns lassen
denn
einfach nur einfach nur mit dem ewigen
durch den supermarkt gehen die
preisschilder durchstreichen höhere
preise dran schreiben das wird nicht die
lösung sein aber ich will auch immer
klar sagen es ist nicht in ordnung und
es vor allem auch nicht alternativlos
wenn die landwirte und der landwirt von
dem euro in der kunde im laden für das
schweinefleisch aus gibt gerade mal 22
cent bekommt meine damen und herren das
einfach eine sauerei dass kammern ändern
das muss man ändern diese koalition
retten
ich bin nicht bereit
ich bin nicht bereits ein ausbeuterisch
system einfach weiter hinzunehmen dass
auf kosten der menschen geht das auf
kosten der tiere geht das auf kosten der
umwelt geht und das auf kosten des
klimas geht worum geht es
warum geht es man kann es vielleicht in
drei punkten zusammenfassen erstens geht
es darum dass alle
hochwertige und bezahlbare lebensmittel
bekommen zweitens geht es darum dass die
landwirte wertschätzung erfahren aber
wertschätzung alleine reicht nicht um
auch davon zu leben sie brauchen auch
wertschöpfung beides gehört zusammen und
dann geht schließlich drittens darum
dass wir dabei klima umwelt
artenvielfalt schon und die tiere
artgerecht behandelt ich will alle 3
enden des cil dreiecks zusammenbringen
ist ein riesiges gesellschaftliches ziel
wir haben auch was davon dort wo es
landwirte gibt dort gibt es auch
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt in einer
landschaft wo es keine landwirte mehr
gibt dazu vorfeld auch der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt da geht
die dorfkultur kaputt wenn es kein
metzger mehr gibt wird kein treffer mehr
geht wenn nicht vor ort geschlachtet
wird dann haben wir auch probleme das
radikalisierung stattfindet
ich habe gesagt ja tiere nutzt hat auch
die pflicht sie bestmöglich zu schützen
was haben wir gemacht statt dass wir
stelle für die tiere bauen haben wir die
tiere an den stall angepasst und noch
den allerletzten effizienzgewinn
rauszuholen stelle sind aber keine
abstellflächen wir haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag
[Applaus]
vorgenommen
die landwirte bei dem umbau der
nutztierhaltung zu unterstützen das
können sie nicht alleine noch in diesem
jahr durch die einführung einer
transparenten und verbindlichen
tierhaltung scan zeichnung ist es zeit
genug dafür
aber wenn es dem tier wenn es dem tier
besser geht's dann muss es halt auch der
bauer und die bäuerin im portemonnaie
spüren dazu der mond die gesamte
wertschöpfungskette entlang der
lebensmittelkette anschauen wir wollen
die asymmetrien zulasten solcher endlich
beenden dazu müssen wir uns ehrlich
machen
landwirtschaftspolitik muss natürlich
sozial sein aber sie ersetzt doch nicht
sozialpolitik meine damen meine herren
bald nichts davon ich hab mir die
reaktion angeschaut werden sehr nach in
der debatte möglicherweise auch hören
ich halte nichts davon die gruppen
gegeneinander auszuspielen
unsere koalition hat sich vorgenommen
gute sozialpolitik zu machen und gut der
landwirtschaftspolitik da steht doch
kein oder zwischendrin sondern ein und
ernährungspolitik
ernährungspolitik ist auch soziale
politik sagt es auch selber als
arbeiterkind wir wollen nicht
akzeptieren wenn menschen mit geringem
einkommen statistisch deutlich
gesteigertes risiko haben chronisch zu
erkranken das kostet auch lebenschancen
man kann es auch positiv wenden es hat
was mit wertschöpfung zu tun mit
wertschätzung für arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer wenn sie gutes essen in der
kantine bekommen und wenn das
wertvollste was wir haben unsere kinder
in der mensa in der schule gesundes
essen möglichst regional angebaut
bekommt das spart man nicht daran
ich bin stolz darauf bin stolz darauf
dass mein haus das
landwirtschaftsministerium er
gleichzeitig auch das
ernährungsministerium ist gesunde
ernährung ist die grundlage für unser
aller wohlbefinden
deshalb wollen wir umgehend eine
ernährungsstrategien aber das ziel ist
weniger zucker weniger fette weniger
salz sind unseren produkten wir wollen
auch die skandalöse
lebensmittelverschwendung endlich
effektiv reduzieren wir wollen
regionales ökologisches essen in der
gemeinschaftsverpflegung stärken
landwirtschaft und forstwirtschaft
stehen auch im fokus wenn es um die
bewältigung der klimakrise geht sie sind
opfer extremer trockenheit von
wetterkapriolen mit die jahreszeiten
nicht mehr dann stattfinden wenn sie
stattfinden sollen aber sie sind auch
treiber der klimakrise durch
futtermittelimporte aus den proben immer
steigende intensivierung und den einsatz
von energie intensiv produzierten
pestiziden und mineraldünger ich will
dass die künftig teil der lösung sind in
dem wir endlich beginnen die potenziale
der kohlenstoffspeicherung zu heben
schutz der moore gezielter humus auf
morgen klima ist waldumbau neue
wiederbewaldung stärkung regionaler
kreisläufe alles der stäbe in der
koalitionsvereinbarung wollen wir
abwarten
wir haben uns
wir haben jetzt auch darauf verständigt
30 prozent öko landbau bis 2030 und zwar
nicht nur in der fläche sondern auch im
supermarktregal auch dafür werben dass
strategie vorlegen ist es richtig dass
der ökologische landbau unser
organisches leitbild bleibt weniger
pestizide weniger dünger und mehr natur
dazu gehört
setzte gehört dass wir in dieser
legislaturperiode ein konzept vorliegen
werden wir die gab zu einer besseren
honorierung von leistungen für klima für
umwelt gesellschaft weiterentwickeln mir
geht es darum die selbstbestimmung der
landwirte zu stärken dazu bekommen die
bäuerinnen und bauern endlich
planungssicherheit die fehlte bislang
und wenn man grad dabei sind
bäuerinnen und bauern haben sie auch
verdient dass sie ein bisschen auch hier
und da vor den falschen freunden in der
politik geschützt werden die sie vor den
brüsseler vorgaben vermeintlich schützt
die man jetzt an damit rat belastung im
grundwasser seen können diese koalition
hat sich darauf verständigt die
erforderlichen maßnahmen zu ergreifen
damit das laufende
vertragsverletzungsverfahren beendet
wird wir wollen
wir wollen klima wir wollen
artenvielfalt schützen das gilt bei uns
im land aber ich wäre ein schlechter
minister wenig vergessen würde dass das
auch den rest der welt betrifft wir
rechnen falsch wenn wir klimaschutz bei
uns einfordern aber nicht schauen was in
der vorproduktion passiert und gibt es
auch genau deshalb bin ich dankbar dafür
dass in der koalitionsvereinbarung auch
die in wallung zwar in lieferketten
stehen auch das gehört dazu dass wir
hier einen guten job macht meine damen
meine herren
wir haben uns große räder vorgenommen in
der koalitionsvereinbarung zum glück
müssen wir das rad nicht neu erfinden
ich kann zurückgreifen auf großartige
arbeit denken sie an die
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft denken
sie an das kompetenznetzwerk tierhaltung
die haben tolle ideen entwickelt aber
jetzt ist es zeit aber was bislang fehlt
der kollege das ist dass die tollen
ideen endlich umgesetzt werden es gibt
kein erkenntnisproblem es gibt ein
anwendungs problem genau das habe ich
mir vorgenommen meine damen meine herren
ich biete ihnen an ich biete ihnen an
dass wir eng zusammenarbeiten die themen
die wir vorgenommen haben die macht man
sich mit 51 prozent gegen 49 prozent
lassen sie uns zusammen arbeiten symbole
von allen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
dem bundesminister für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
ja mehr ökolandbau in tirol lebe in
ernährungsstrategien für gutes essen und
bewegung und sehr häufig hat hier müsste
mir die landwirtinnen und landwirte
angesprochen geht zu unterstützen deren
arbeit wert zu schätzen
auch das hat er sich vorgenommen steffen
bilger jetzt der nächste redner für die
union
bundesminister özdemir zu ihrem
amtsantritt wünsche ich ihnen seitens
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion auch
persönlich alles gute wir werden sie
steht begleiten als wachsame als
kritische opposition aber auch als
politische kraft die gute und richtige
vorschläge unterstützt
und vorschläge die haben sie in den
zurückliegenden fünf wochen seit ihrer
ernennung ja wirklich schon etliche
gemacht der abdruck des gepäckträgers
ihres fahrrads war wahrscheinlich noch
auf der ernennungsurkunde des
bundespräsidenten zu erkennen schon
haben sie sich den nächsten titel in der
bundesregierung verdient nämlich den des
ankündigungsminister höhere preise für
lebensmittel damit politisch verordnete
speisepläne staatliche vorgaben für den
zucker oder salzgehalt von lebensmittel
keine strafen fürs containern dieser
bundesminister verspricht wie noch
keiner vor ihm
der nennung
der ernennung zum
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister campus ihr
wahrscheinlich auch etwas überraschend
denn ansonsten hätten sie auch dafür
sorgen können dass diese vielen schönen
ankündigungen sich jetzt schon im
koalitionsvertrag wiederfinden grundlage
der politik der bundesregierung laut
koalitionsvertrag und sie diese ganzen
vorhaben diese ganzen ankündigungen
nicht im koalitionsvertrag steht
jedenfalls sehr wenig dazu vielleicht
wollen ja die redner von spd und fdp
gleich noch erläutern wie sie sich zu
den einzelnen vorschlägen stellen leider
muss ich ihnen ohnehin sagen auch wenn
sie so tun als ob mit ihnen alles ganz
neu würde auch sie werden die
natürlichen und wirtschaftlichen
gesetzmäßigkeiten und erfordernisse
nicht neu erfinden können auch und einem
bundesminister auch
und einen bundesminister als die mir
wird die henne das ei legen auch unter
einem bundesminister özdemir würde es
hoffentlich so etwas wie persönlichen
geschmack und freie konsumenten
entscheidung geben und das ist im
übrigen auch gut so meine damen und
herren auch unter einem bundesminister
mehr bewegen wir uns in der eu
rechtsrahmen und seinen binnenmarkt
sowie im internationalen handel und
globalen märkten mit harter konkurrenz
und enormen preisdruck und auch und
einem bundesminister özdemir sollten die
ernährungssicherung für alle mit
möglichst mehrere fairen preisen und die
einkommenssicherung unser land wird ein
ganz wesentliches hauptaugenmerk der
agrarpolitik sein
und mit verlaub herr minister diese
zentralen erkenntnisse kommen wir bei
den botschaften die sie bislang aus
gesendet haben viel zu kurz viele
verbraucher werden von steigenden
lebensmittelpreisen belastet und sorgen
sich dass diese spirale so weitergeht
mal ganz abgesehen von den lasten der
allgemeinen teuerungsrate und der
entwicklung bei den energiepreisen und
das sind sorgen die auch familien haben
die auch menschen mit mittleren
einkommen haben und all diese menschen
spielen zuverlässig in ihren interviews
und so auch in ihren reden wie heute
keine rolle
herr minister es dem er sie sagen der
preis gerade für fleisch müsse die
ökologische wahrheit wiedergeben das
hört sich gut an ich frage sie aber was
soll das konkret heißen wie hoch muss
denn aus ihrer sicht der preis sein für
ein schnitzel für eine currywurst wird
es kilogramm hackfleisch mit ihren
ankündigungen zu höheren
lebensmittelpreisen erreichen sie nur
eines sie sorgen für verunsicherung
damit wir uns richtig verstehen auch wir
wollen qualitativ hochwertige
lebensmittel die unseren landwirten ein
gutes einkommen sichern wir wollen
lebensmittel die in deutschland
produziert werden und nicht irgendwo im
ausland wo oft deutlich geringere
auflagen für tierhaltung umwelt und
klimaschutz bestehen und wir wollen eine
stärkung der regionalen erzeugung
dadurch neue wertschätzung und
wertschöpfung in unseren ländlichen
räumen und wir wollen aber auch
lebensmittel sich alle leisten könnt und
nicht nur die grüne wählerschaft meine
damen und herren
das alles zu gewährleisten der
bundesminister ist ihre aufgabe nicht
nur so zu tun als ob die lebensmittel in
deutschland allesamt zu ramschpreisen
über die ladentheke gingen denn so ist
es nun wirklich nicht sie haben sich
selbst als obersten anwalt der
landwirtinnen und landwirte bezeichnet
diesen ruf müssen sich erst noch
verdienen einiges was im
koalitionsvertrag dazu steht passt gar
nicht dazu auch ihren hinweis gestatte
mir diese anmerkung landwirt es sollten
den wandel in der landwirtschaft hat mit
cannabis anbau gestalten finde ich dann
schon reichlich zynisch
und überhaupt passt ja auch die
begeisterung für die legalisierung einer
schädlichen droge nicht so ganz dazu
oder sie andererseits den menschen zum
schutz ihrer gesundheit vorschreiben
wollen wie viel zucker oder fett sie in
ihren lebensmitteln überhaupt noch zu
sich nehmen lassen
doch zurück zu den themen die die
landwirtschaft wirklich bewegen von
einem anwalt einem modernen
landwirtschaft erwarte ich auch mut vor
den eigenen parteifreunden sie nehmen am
krad kontrast des
bundesumweltministeriums in der
kommenden woche teil und ich hoffe dass
die anliegen der landwirtschaft nicht
komplett grüne umwelt wollte kunde
geordnet werden vom obersten land an wir
an walter landwirte erwarte ich
jedenfalls das ja auch dort klare worte
im interesse der landwirtschaft findet
überzeugen sie ihre parteifreundin die
bundesumweltministerium doch bitte davon
dass der abstrakt beruf frau lemke nach
weniger pflanzenschutzmittel in der
landwirtschaft so lange unglaubwürdig
ist wie alternativen dazu nicht
vorangebracht werden und es ist sehr
bedauerlich dass diese bundesregierung
beim thema neue züchtungsmethoden
offensichtlich positions- und sprachlos
ist aber geht es um neue pflanzensorten
wie zum beispiel im klimawandel besser
standhalten können
meine bitte deshalb anziehen hören sie
nicht auf die grünen befindlichkeiten um
sie herum lassen sie die großen chancen
die diese technologien versprechen nicht
ungenutzt liegen es ist wichtig dass ein
großer teil unserer lebensmittel auch in
unserem land produziert wird und mit
ihrer politik laufen wir gefahr dass wir
immer mehr von importen abhängig werden
auch deswegen müssen sie moderne
technologien in den blick nehmen um der
zeuge hierzulande zu unterstützen herr
minister wir haben ihre ankündigungen
vernommen wir sind nun gespannt auf ihre
taten überzeugen sie uns vor allem aber
die landwirte in unserem land mit einer
politik die den die interessen der
bäuerlichen landwirtschaft vertritt und
die des verbrauchers der sich qualitativ
hochwertige aber eben auch bezahlbare
lebensmittel wünscht mit einer politik
die umwelt natur und klimaschutz einen
guten ausgleich bringt ganz ohne
schwarz-weiß-malerei grüne vereinfachung
ohne spalterische politik und
bilder war dass stephen ritter
fraktionsvorsitzender der
cdu/csu-fraktion und die vorstellungen
zwischen hier der unionsfraktion und dem
grünen landwirtschaftsminister die
liegen doch relativ weit auseinander das
werden interessante debatten in dieser
legislatur und sie haben es gesehen
petra pau hat jetzt hier die
sitzungsleitung als
bundestags-vizepräsidentin übernommen
und ruft auf den ex trainer matthias
miersch für die spd kolleginnen und
kollegen herr wenn es der letzte mir im
namen der spd bundestagsfraktion möchte
ich ihnen ganz herzlich für ihre aufgabe
gratulieren und ihnen versichern dass
zumindestens mir mit ausnahme des
baden-württembergischen schlangen diese
rede wirklich so gut gefallen hat dass
wir glaube ich sagen können sie haben
unsere unterstützung indem in jedem von
hier aufgezeigten vorhaben liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und herr kollege bilde ich habe sie in
den letzten jahren ja jetzt nicht so als
landwirtschafts politischen experten
wahrgenommen müssen sie auch nicht sein
aber dann ein minister der wenige tage
im amt ist als
ankündigungsminister zu bezeichnen wo
man doch jahrelang diesen ministerposten
begleitet hat und außer hochglanz nichts
geliefert hat das ist schon eine
anmaßung
nein nein herr stegemann das müssen sie
sich jetzt gefallen lassen ihre fraktion
ist durchtränkt mit altem denken mit
funktionärs denken und die landwirte in
diesem land haben längst verstanden dass
damit nicht zukunft zu gestalten ist die
wir kolleginnen und kollegen
das was sie über jahre hier gepredigt
haben und es kam ja wieder auch zwischen
den zeilen stichwort gegen den markt
gegen die globalisierung könne man
nichts tun das ist die sackgasse weil
wir hier an dieser stelle tatsächlich
auch den landwirten in deutschland viel
zumuten weil wir andere standards haben
wollen aber wenn sie gleichzeitig dann
sagen es muss der markt regeln dann
passiert genau das was wir in der
deutschen landwirtschaft über jahre
beobachten können die höfe sterben und
sie werden gerade nicht unterstützt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
politisch hatte sie eine frage oder
bemerkungen des abgeordneten springen 1
die kollegen sind ja jetzt gleich dran
die können dann darauf erwidern das ist
die ba debattenkultur die ich der pflege
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich will schon sagen dass ärzte mehr an
einer stelle für mich jedenfalls die
entscheidende frage gestellt hat hat
nämlich das zukunftsfeld landwirtschaft
mit dem gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
in den mittelpunkt gestellt und wir
leben in den großen bereichen klima auch
corona aber auch landwirtschaftspolitik
die zunehmende polarisierung
dieser gesellschaft daraus werden keine
nachhaltigen konzept die
sozialdemokratie hat sich gegründet weil
wir gesehen haben dass wir es nur
gemeinsam schaffen können und deswegen
sind die vorarbeiten der
zukunftskommission landwirtschaft wo
nicht die betonköpfe drin saßen sondern
wo menschen drin gesessen haben die
empathie gegenüber die an der anderen
haltung eingenommen haben und dann
handlungsempfehlungen aufgeschrieben
haben dieses ist so wertvoll für unsere
vierjähriger arbeit jetzt dass sie zu
recht darauf hingewiesen haben dass wir
sowohl die empfehlungen der borchert
kommission die an einigen stellen noch
konkretisiert werden müssen und der
empfehlung der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft diese als gute grundlage
sehen und ich will im namen der spd
bundestagsfraktion nicht noch einmal
ausdrücklich bedanken bei allen die
daran mitgewirkt haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen vor uns
gegen vier sicherlich sehr anstrengende
jahre
denn all die konzepte wie hier
vorgetragen werden verdienen es
natürlich bei der umsetzung sehr genau
gewichte zu werden ich will weil ich
susanne mittag nicht vorgreifen will ein
punkt sagen
das ist dass tierschutz label wir haben
dreieinhalb jahre ist in dieser
koalition in der großen koalition nicht
geschafft ein kompromiss zu finden
ich glaube dass dieses ein ganz
wichtiges element ist dass
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher nicht
vom markt
deklarierte labels vorgesetzt bekommen
sondern dass der staat die allgemeinheit
tatsächlich nachhaltigkeit ein bild gibt
und dann verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher auch entscheiden können und
sie haben zu recht darauf hingewiesen
dass landwirte unterstützt werden müssen
wenn sie umstellen die debatte in der
grossen koalition war dreieinhalb jahre
davon geprägt mehr geld ins system und
dann wird das alles so funktioniert es
nicht wir haben wissenschaftliche
expertise die aufzeigt dass das system
an sich krank ist und deswegen müssen
wir an vielen stellen auch systematisch
eine neuerung gehen damit böden
geschützt werden damit tiere geschützt
werden und damit die landwirte die jeden
tag arbeiten tatsächlich auch das
verdienen was sie verdienen sollen und
dann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen bin ich
mir eins sicher werden wir eine
riesen-chance heben die auch
gesellschaftspolitisch gar nicht
geringzuschätzen ist und im übrigen mit
der energiepolitik ganz eng
zusammenhängt es geht auch dabei um die
stärkung der ländlichen räume und die
ländlichen räume zu verbinden mit
wertschöpfung der zukunft ist glaube ich
ein ganz wichtiger
gesellschaftspolitischer schluss
wirklich danke für die aufmerksamkeit
matthias kahle aus der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd fraktion
und von der zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft war jetzt schon häufiger
die rede die bayern eingesetzt worden
unter dem eindruck verstärkte proteste
aber dazu gleich noch mal
jetzt gibt es eine kurzintervention
damit begonnen sich an den
landwirtschaftsminister blendend mit der
aussage dieser landwirtschaftsminister
hätte die volle unterstützung für jedes
vorhaben nun eines seiner vorhaben ist
für höhere lebensmittelpreise ein zu
sich einzusetzen und das angesichts
einer
inflationsentwicklung in deutschland die
sehr beunruhigend ist für viele menschen
die inflation liegt inzwischen bei 5,3
prozent
die lebensmittelpreise sind um sechs
prozent gestiegen wir haben in
deutschland sieben millionen menschen
die von die arbeits
sozialleistungen beantragen müssen wir
haben 13,4 millionen die von armut
bedroht sind jeder fünfte arbeitet im
niedriglohnsektor da ist das budget auf
kante genäht da ist gar kein geld mehr
für weitere ausgaben insbesondere
deshalb nicht weil aufgrund der grünen
ideologie und zugegeben auch andere
effekte der diesel inzwischen
unbezahlbar ist jetzt doch mal meine
frage an sie ist eine ganz einfache ja
nein frage sind sie auch für höhere
lebensmittelpreise
obwohl ihr kanzler mit dem thema soziale
gerechtigkeit in den wahlkampf gezogen
ist dankeschön rené ist bringe für die
afg hat es gefragt
sehr geehrter herr kollege ich weiß
nicht wo sie eben gesessen haben aber
gucken sie sich die rede des
landwirtschaftsministers noch einmal an
er hat explizit darauf hingewiesen dass
höhere preise automatisch überhaupt noch
keine höheren vergütung für die
landwirte haben und das ist unsere
meinung ebenso wenn wir tatsächlich
landwirten ein einkommen garantieren
wollen um mit gut gewirtschaftet werden
kann werden wir uns das system
werden wir uns die wertschöpfungskette
angucken müssen der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister darauf
hingewiesen wie viel von einem euro bei
dem landwirt landet das ist die
gesellschaftspolitische und die
wirtschaftspolitische fragestellung der
wir uns widmen müssen und ja ich sage
ihnen auch dass was wir teilweise auch
in supermärkten erleben das ist nicht
mit der pauschalen ja nein frage zu
beantworten denn die lebensmittel haben
sehr unterschiedliche höhen aber was am
ende teilweise auf den ladentheken für
preise liegt
das hat mit fairem handel und mit
wettbewerb so wenig zu tun wie auch mit
der sozialen frage denn letztlich
brauchen wir andere steuerungen um auf
der einen seite gute sozialpolitik zu
machen und auf der anderen seite tiere
landwirte und auch natur zu schützen das
was sie hier machen ist ein
schwarz-weiß-bild das entspricht ihrer
parteipolitik die sie überall ziehen
aber damit werden sie keine zukunft
gestalten können und insofern lassen sie
uns die nächsten vier jahre ruhig weiter
streiten über diese frage
es hört sich ein wenig so an als wäre
das in der tat dieses spannungsfeld was
wir jetzt wirklich mit den landwirten
ein gute preise für ihre produkte und
den verbraucher nicht zu hohe preise
dass jeder sich das leisten kann also
eine frage für diese legislatur mit
sicherheit nächster redner jetzt stefan
tutschka für die fgm
sicherheit leider von der tribüne aus zu
ihnen reden die
bundesregierung dazu entschieden wird
die spaltung zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften gesunden wie ich einer bin
verstärkt weiter zu betreiben aber diese
art von gesellschaftlicher ausgrenzung
käme ja leider auch in der
landwirtschaft ja seit vorgestern sein
wir mittendrin in der neuesten
professionellen schmutzkampagne gegen
die moderne landwirtschaft losgetreten
natürlich wie immer vor den grünen durch
die veröffentlichung des pestizid atlas
von ihrer politischen stiftungen dieses
dokument bedient ideologische vorurteile
und die ausschließlich der
desinformation den tonnen zahlen und
daten würden der wissenschaftlichen
studie
oder überprüfung nicht standhalten ob um
fakten geht ja den grünen ja überhaupt
nicht das ist ja wie beim klimawandel
oder bei der tour de oder bei der
colonia krise geht es ihnen nur um
stimmungsmache und dem fall trifft der
heimische landwirtschaft
es wunderte anitas die grüne
umweltministerin also liebe landwirte
tut mir leid umwelt und landwirtschaft
den grünen diese finews sofort begrüßt
besonders skandalös ist ja alles
mittlerweile staatliche behörden wie das
umweltbundesamt an solchen und
unwissenschaftlichen stimmungs machen
beteiligt sein der letzte mir beim
amtsantritt haben sie
lautstark betont dass sie die oberste
anwalt der deutschen bauern sein wollen
na ja dann immer sehr grundsätzlich kein
wort aber dann muss es ja auffordern das
ist schon vor der schmutzkampagne der
eigenen partei distanzieren und sich
schützen vor die deutsche landwirtschaft
stellen denn 1
denn eines muss uns allen hier klar sein
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert dieser
landwirtschaft egal ob konventionell
oder ökologisch wir sind nicht die die
den sport eben vorantreiben wir brauchen
alle ohne einsatz von
pflanzenschutzmitteln und ender
undenkbar denn nur dank
pflanzenschutzmittel haben wir ernte und
somit auch ernährungssicherheit verzicht
oder verbot würde die versorgung der
heimischen und regionalen lebensmitteln
massiv gefährden das müssen sie dann den
menschen aber selbst erklären was dies
verlangt ist für deutschland bedeutet
das ja heute schon nettoimporteur von
lebensmitteln ist
es ist auch eine feindliche
stimmungsmache wird diese die die
mitverantwortung dafür sie tragen und
immer weniger bauern wollen überhaupt
noch bauern bleiben junge hofnachfolge
überlegen sich angesichts solcher
fehlender wertschätzung ob sie nicht
einfach im online shop vornehmen wo sie
30 tage urlaub haben und ein
vernünftiges geld verdienen aber das
sollte denn eigentlich so wie jetzt die
vor der kerb egal von spd und union die
alarmglocken bei und schön dazu kommt
der immense wirtschaftliche
gesprochen sie wollen mehr verdienen
oder sollen wir verdienen die auf
bäuerlichen betriebe kostet jedes jahr
schließen 10.000 bahnhof und gute worte
das ist jetzt gemacht haben wird daran
nichts ändern denn sie werden daran
gemessen ob sie die regeln noch
weiterhin verschärfen und somit das
höfesterben
vorantreiben
und wenn sie das höfesterben
vorantreiben dann werden die renten
ländlichen regionen das ist ebenso hoch
gelobt haben aussterben denn ich komme
von der ländlichen region wir haben auch
sehr viele landwirte aber das sind nicht
glücklich mit ihnen als minister wie als
heute auf jeden fall einen der links
latour juli fest an der seite der
deutschen bauern stehen und uns für gute
wettbewerbsfähige rahmenbedingungen in
der deutschen wirtschaft einsetzen denn
heimat braucht bauern und umweltschutz
landwirtschaft und tierschutz ist nur
mit der oft wie möglich dort meine damen
[Applaus]
während der kollege dr gero hocker für
die fdp-fraktion sein weg zum redepult
findet und auch gleich das wort hat
bitte ich alle zu überprüfen ob ihnen im
alpha der debatte gegebenenfalls die
maske von der nase gerutscht ist und das
zu korrigieren
danke sie haben das mal
[Applaus]
werte frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der minister hat in den
vergangenen tagen und wochen eine ganz
zentrale und existenzielle frage
aufgeworfen nämlich die frage was uns
lebensmittel wert sind und damit auch
was uns die arbeit derjenigen wert ist
die diese lebensmittel erzeugung und
natürlich ist der preis dafür dass
zentrale signal für diese bewertung aber
meine damen und herren eben auch nur
eines wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen dass
gegenwärtig nur gut die hälfte der
geernteten und produzierten lebensmittel
in deutschland überhaupt nur konsumiert
werden weil der verbraucher häufig genug
lebensmittel als nicht verbraucht würdig
erachtet wenn sie bestimmten normen
nicht entsprechen und in seiner
wahrnehmung unansehnlich sind und sie
deswegen den weg nie in die regale ist
einzelhandels finden ist das auch eine
frage von wertschätzung lebensmittel
gegenüber
und ich das leben ganz ausdrücklich wir
müssen uns da allen stück selber auch
mit in die pflicht nehmen ich habe den
eindruck dass in den jahrzehnten der
überflussgesellschaft
viele tatsächlich es verloren haben die
fähigkeit sich auch auf ihre eigenen
sinne zu verlassen bei der frage ob ein
lebensmittel noch genießbar ist und
allzu häufig wird wenn das
mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum sozusagen am
horizont sich nur abzeichnet der
ungeöffnete joghurtbecher und die un-
angebrochene butter einfach weggeworfen
meine damen und herren auch das ist eine
frage von wertschätzung für lebensmittel
die genießbar wären in unserem lande und
deswegen müssen wir diese frage auch um
finde ich ja beantwortet meine damen und
herren
landwirtschaft muss gegenwärtig so viele
herausforderungen erfüllen wie noch nie
zuvor die von der gesellschaft an sie
herangetragen werden und trotzdem
gelingt es den landwirten in deutschland
mit immer weniger fläche die ihnen zur
verfügung steht immer hochwertigere und
auch immer mehr lebensmittel zu erzeugen
das ist quasi die erfolgreiche quadratur
des kreises und man muss es wenn wir
über wertschätzung diskutieren ob man
hier so deutlich sagen wenn trotz
explodierender
bevölkerungszahlen auf diesem planeten
relativ immer weniger menschen in der
welt hunger leiden müssen dann ist das
auch ein erfolg der modernen
landwirtschaft meine sehr vernahm und
herren dann funktioniert so etwas nur
durch effizienz und vor allem auch durch
technischen fortschritt auch das gehört
zur wertschätzung dazu dass er dieser
stelle mal so deutlich zu artikulieren
ich werde häufig gefragt welches
lebensmittel siege aus der perspektive
von nachhaltigkeit tierschutz denn das
beste wäre meine antwort ist eigentlich
immer die gleiche meine damen und herren
wer gleichzeitig hohe tierwohl standards
honorieren möchte
lebensmittel auch mit geringen co2
emission konsumieren und etwas für
biodiversität und nachhaltigkeit tun
möchte der möge bitte vor allem darauf
achten dass die lebensmittel in
heimischen gefilden entstanden sind
meine damen und herren denn wir müssen
uns mal ehrlich machen sie werden
weltweit kaum ein land finden dass
derart hohe standards definiert an
tierhaltung an lebensmittelproduktion
und deswegen muss es unsere aufgabe sein
das auch in die politische kommunikation
einzupflegen dass der konsum von in
unserem land erzeugten lebensmittel
diese quadratur des kreises möglich
macht der nirgendwo in der welt sind die
standards höher und wir müssen da
ehrlicherweise auch den verbraucher
endlich in die pflicht nehmen denn es
kann nicht sein dass er immer höhere
standards fordert dann aber wenn es zum
schwur kommt an der ladentheke nicht
bereit ist auch diese hohen
anforderungen diese hohen standards zu
honorieren durch einen angemessenen
preis meine damen und herren auch das
ist eine frage von wertschätzung
und ich gebe gerne zu natürlich ist es
nicht immer zu jeden erkennbar
woher auch vor produkte stammen und
deswegen ist es richtig dass diese
koalition sich sehr ambitioniert
übrigens das haben andere innerhalb von
vier jahren nicht hinbekommen
bereits im jahre 2022 eine verbindliche
haltungs und
herkunftskennzeichnung einführen will
und das auch national und auch
international europäisches rollen will
weil sie es eben nicht hinnehmen wollen
dass sich der verbraucher immer wieder
doch aus der verantwortung stiehlt und
behauptet er könne nicht nachvollziehen
woher das lebensmittel stand dass meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ist ein
großer schritt in richtung auch zu mehr
wettbewerbsfähigkeit für landwirte in
deutschland der verbraucher wird eben
auch in die pflicht genommen seinen
worten taten folgen zu lassen zweite
kolleginnen und kollegen
beide damen ich verstehe fastens worden
nicht mehr meine damen und herren
landwirte sind vor allem unternehmer
und die brauchen keine
almosen die brauchen keine bauern
milliarden und die brauchen vor allem
auch keine nationalen alleingänge wie
zum beispiel das beim insektenschutz in
den vergangenen vier jahren allzu häufig
der fall gewesen ist die sind
unternehmer und deswegen brauchen sie
von der politik vor allem verlässliche
rahmenbedingungen innerhalb derer sie
ihre unternehmerischen entscheidungen
ihre invest für uns entscheidungen
verlässlich treffen können eine sehr
schöne damen herren und landwirte
brauchen eben auch ein verbraucher der
wahrhaftig ist und seinen anforderungen
taten folgen lässt ich kann ihnen
versichern meine damen und herren sah
ich den landwirten im ganzen land und
den menschen in den ländlichen räumen
diese haltung hat meine fraktion den
vergangenen vier jahren in diesem hohen
hause vertreten und man kann sich darauf
verlassen dass wir diese haltung auch in
den kommenden vier jahren diesem ort
geben werde herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
theo clemens hocker war das für die
fdp-fraktion und es gab kritische
zwischenrufe von der
fraktionsvorsitzenden der linken hier
sehen sie noch mal am ihrer momentan
allerdings verstehen konnte man das
jetzt auf die entfernung nicht aber die
linke hat jetzt sozusagen die
gelegenheit zur erwiderung
nämlich hier mit der abgeordneten ihrer
latendorf für die linke und es ist ihre
erste rede hier im deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich komme aus
mecklenburg vorpommern ein demograf der
universität greifswald sagt immer dem
ländlichen alle räume umso mehr ist die
stärkung der ländlichen räume ein
wesentlicher bestandteil der politik
meiner fraktion da geht es auch um
daseinsvorsorge um infrastruktur und
mobilität gute lebensbedingungen für
alle hier muss sich endlich mehr bewegen
die landwirtschaft ist ein wichtiger
prägender teil im ländlichen raum der
verbinden kann und ein wichtiger
wirtschaftszweig daher bedarf die
landwirtschaftspolitik unser allergrößte
aufmerksamkeit aber schauen wir genauer
hin die landwirtschaft ist im umbruch
große herausforderungen stehen an
atemschutz klimawandel artgerechte
tierhaltung solchen sp gerade dies geht
nicht reibungslos die politik der
bundesregierung natürlich bisher mehr
plan als tun mit dem blick der sozialen
opposition auf die pläne der ampel
findet man wenig zu den zentralen
anforderungen an eine zeitgemäße und
sozialgerechte agrarpolitik in der rede
des ministers kamen zwar einige punkte
vor aber wie gesagt nicht im
koalitionsvertrag ich hätte da mehr
erwartet was verbrieft ist ich vermisse
völlig aussagen zur sozialen absicherung
der landwirte und landwirtinnen und ich
frage mich manchmal ob die spd überhaupt
am verhandlungstisch saß sie hätten
gerade die änderung der einkommen in der
land forst und fischereiwirtschaft fest
schreiben müssen sie hätten eine
konkrete forderung zur
sozialversicherungspflichtigen arbeits
und ausbildungsplätzen und zur
tarifbindung erwartet und ich eine
aussage zu dem völlig meist
unterbezahlten saison arbeitern ebenso
auf die konkrete einbeziehung der
landwirte und land irgendwo politische
entscheidung fehlt mir nichts ist zu
finden von einer stärkung ihrer
beteiligung an der steuerung der
marktprozesse und ich hätte auch eine
aussage zu einem erleichterten zugang zu
grund und boden für die regionale
landwirtschaft erwartet zum beispiel
durch die bodenpreis bremse um
spekulationen zu verhindern
kurzum wir brauchen eine nachsteuerung
weil der ausrichtung der agrarpolitik
und bin gespannt was von der rede des
ministers am ende übrig bleibt wir
brauchen eine regionale
wirtschaftskreisläufe mit
nachvollziehbar an verketten aktuell
haben wir ein weitgehend unregulierten
welthandel mit einer preis- und standard
und mit einem preis und standard
unterbietungswettbewerb der ökologisch
verheerend und noch dazu unzuverlässig
ist und unseren markt kaputt macht auch
in der ernährungspolitik hätten wir von
der bundesregierung eine soziale
schwerpunktsetzung erwartet zum beispiel
eine kostenfreie schulen und kita
verpflegung als eine wichtige maßnahme
für eine gesunde und nachhaltige
ernährung auch gesunde ernährung muss
gelernt werden dann dann da
die raum preissteigerungen insbesondere
bei grundnahrungsmitteln bei obst und
gemüse müssen aufhören niemand der auf
soziale leistung angewiesen ist kommt in
der bio abteilung sehr weit da haben die
sozialverbände recht also bedarf eine
wesentliche erhöhung der kaufkraft
sozial benachteiligen damit gesunde
ernährung überhaupt möglich wird und
was muss nun folgen der preisdruck der
lebensmittelkonzerne auf die produzenten
und produzent muss endlich aufhören
anzufangen wäre aus meiner sicht bei den
billig lockangeboten mit lebensmitteln
die voll auf die erzeuger durchgedrückt
werden sonst fliegen sie aus der listung
ich bitte sie lachs braten für 444 pro
kilo wer soll dafür produzieren und
davon kommt ja nur ein geringer teil an
solche preise bedeuten geringschätzung
für die waren und damit auch für die
arbeit der landwirte was wir aber
brauchen ist eine bewusste wertschätzung
landwirtschaftlicher produkte und weder
vom markt drückte ramschpreise noch
pauschale preissteigerung die nicht beim
erzeuger ankommen helfen uns weiter sehr
geehrte damen und herren die linke
fordert die bundesregierung auf für
unsere landwirte und landwirte unbedingt
nachzubessern wir fordern einen umbau
der agrarpolitik hin zu regionalen
wirtschaftskreisläufen die abkehr von
exportorientierung und der
profitmaximierung für internationale
konzerne schluss mit dem ausverkauf von
grund und boden die bodenpreis bremse
muss kommen und der
bvvg flächen also die bundes fläche
müssen unverzüglich und aus meiner sicht
kostenfrei inländer hand gegeben werden
damit diese dann der regionalen
wirtschaft zugute kommen können für eine
flächen gebundene tierhaltung die ja für
die es ein umbau bedarf muss die
landwirtschaft gefördert werden das geht
nicht von alleine und naturschutz durch
die landwirtschaft muss ebenso honoriert
werden da werden sie zurzeit sehr allein
gelassen gerade gestern hat der bauer
trabanten mit hilfe gerufen mit bezug
auf die steigenden preise für dünger und
energie und wenn die landwirte unsere
landwirte wie der mit traktoren in
berlin einfahren und für eine
transformation in der agrarpolitik
streiten dann sagen wir linken recht
haben sie vielen dank für aufmerksamkeit
erste riege der neuen abgeordneten in
latendorf für die linksfraktion und
siebe künftig im ausschuss für ernährung
und landwirtschaft zu sitzen
und sich also
mit diesen ganzen punkten wahrscheinlich
häufiger zu wort melden und jetzt noch
eine erste rede von einer neuen
abgeordneten und zwar wären wir jetzt
auf den reihen der bündnisgrünen eine
neue abgeordnete hören das ist so immer
ja
frau präsidentin liebe kollege eine
hitzige debatte heute wo man ehrlich das
ist auch gut so nach 16 jahren
landwirtschaftlichen oder
landwirtschafts politischen stillstand
ist es doch wirklich trink mal notwendig
dass wir uns über veränderungen
unterhalten und bei veränderungen der
gehören hitzige debatten nun mal einfach
auch dazu wir reden heute dank des
ministers auch mal über das thema
lebensmittelpreise und ich danke cem
özdemir an der stelle wirklich sehr
dafür dieses thema mal auch klar und
offen zu benennen und um auf die reden
meiner vor gegnerinnen einzugehen
natürlich ist es ein gigantisches
problem wenn lebensmittelpreise in
deutschland schneller steigen als die
einkommen aber da müssen wir doch mal
zwischen ursache und wirkung
unterscheiden steigende
lebensmittelpreise sind nicht schuld
daran dass unsere tariflöhne in
deutschland kaum erhöht werden und die
lösung für dieses problem sind ganz
sicher nicht ramsch preise für
lebensmittel sondern die lösungen die
lösung ist eine anständige sozial und
arbeitspolitik die lösung ist ein
höherer mindestlohn
die lösung sind studenten
die lösung ist die kindersicherung und
noch vieles mehr und genau das wird
unsere regierung auf den weg bringen wir
nur so schaffen wir es auch dass wir
soziales ökologisches und tierschutz
zusammendenken und eben nicht mehr
gegeneinander ausspielen
was wir ganz sicher nicht machen der
wird ist die debatte um faire
lebensmittelpreise weiter zu
verschleppen das sind wir nämlich
insbesondere den landwirten in
deutschland dringend schuldig die sicher
kaum über wasser halten können in dem
aktuellen system das geld was für
landwirtschaftliche erzeugnisse
aktuell erworben der das reicht kaum um
die kosten zu decken das zeigt nicht für
eine gute existenzsicherung das zeigt
schon drei mal nicht um die bedingungen
für die millionen von tieren die in
unseren wirklich prekären system der
deutschen massentierhaltung leben und
sterben müssen zu verbessern damit muss
schluss sein und klar wir brauchen geld
für das was gibt's da
die finanzierung für die höheren
standards beim fleisch wie soll getragen
werden durch alle die fleisch
konsumieren möchten und wir unterstützen
die verbraucher finden bei der
transparenz durch die verbindliche
einführung der tierhaltung scan
zeichnung ein längst überflüssige oder
längst überfälliger schritt überflüssig
wenn dies auf gar keinen fall zu
ehrlichkeit gehört auch dazu wenn wir
unsere klimaziele ernst nehmen und wenn
wir den tierschutz in deutschland ernst
nehmen dann müssen wir auch wegkommen
von diesen enormen zahlen der
tierhaltung und für all die
die die tötung von tieren für ihren
konsum nicht mehr unterstützen möchte
oder ihren konsum reduzieren möchten
müssen wir auch gute angebote schaffen
das heißt pflanzliche ernährung
unterstützen das heißt vegetarisch
vegane angebote unterstützen und zwar
auch flächendeckend war nur so schaffen
wir echte wahlfreiheit für alle
bürgerinnen und bürger die tierleid
freie nachhaltige und klimaschonende
ernährung wollen und ich freue mich sehr
auf all das was unsere regierung hier in
den nächsten jahren auf den weg bringt
dass es veränderungen vielen dank
in der neue abt ortet hier können sie
kommt wie cem özdemir aus baden
württemberg war dort auch
spitzenkandidatin übrigens der grüne
jugend für die bundestagswahl hat ihren
wahlkreis und karlsruher direkt gewonnen
und ist studierte wirtschaftsingenieurin
vom hintergrund und für die
zukünftig im ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft arbeiten für die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren normalerweise
debattieren wir im januar aus anlass der
internationalen grünen woche über
ernährung und landwirtschaft leider hat
corona uns auch hier einen strich durch
die rechnung gemacht deshalb ist es gut
dass sie der bundesminister nun heute
hier im deutschen bundestag ihre erste
agrarpolitische rede zu jahresbeginn
halten ich wünsche ihnen zunächst eine
glückliche hand in ihrer amtsführung
persönlich alles gute und gottes segen
es gibt die gute tradition dass sich
eine neue opposition mindestens hundert
tage mit kritik an der regierungsarbeit
zurückhalten sollte leider kann ich mich
an diese regel heute hier nicht halten
zu groß ist die verantwortung die wir
als parlamentarier haben um sie in
konstruktiver weise auf wichtige
kurskorrekturen hinzuweisen denn leider
minister hat die neue bundesregierung
gleich in ihren ersten wochen einen
fehlstart hingelegt da ist zum beispiel
das unwürdige agierende management der
korona pandemie erst das auslaufen
lassen der epidemischen lage dann wieder
beschränkungen bei uns nämlich habe ich
niedersachsen im land der kartoffel
knolle quasi sagt man dazu raus aus den
kartoffeln rein in die kartoffeln aber
ich will hier nun konkret beim thema
landwirtschaft bleiben und auch werden
denn auch hier haben sie sich als neuer
minister schon mehrfach vergaloppiert
ich nenne erstens da schon viel
diskutierte beispiel lebensmittelpreise
ja wir wollen doch auch dass unsere
landwirte für ihre hochwertigen
lebensmittel fair entlohnt werden und
ich glaube das hat man ja auch gerade
vernommen da gibt es hier im plenarsaal
sicherlich keinen der das ernsthaft
anders aber wenn sie herr minister den
vielen bauern in deutschland die
hoffnung machen dass sie die preise für
landwirtschaftliche produkte
wollen dann müssen sie nicht nur den
edlen wunsch äußern dann müssen sie auch
erklären wie sie das konkret umsetzen
wollen landläufig heißt es
bekanntermaßen angebot und nachfrage
bestimmen den kreis was aber machen sie
in sachen angebot und nachfrage auf der
angebotsseite also auf der seite der
bauernfamilien deutet alles auf weitere
kostensteigerungen hin so unterstützen
sie zum beispiel auch ihre kollegin frau
lemke die beim pflanzenschutz nur nach
mehr bürokratie und nach neuem
ordnungsrecht ruft von
technologieoffenheit bei neuen
pflanzenschutzmitteln bei neuen
wirkstoffen oder bei neuen züchtung
technologien keine spur auf der
nachfrageseite also auf der seite der
verbraucher wollen sie sicherlich viele
neue akzente setzen das haben wir ja
gerade auch noch mal gehört aber gewiss
zum beispiel den fleischkonsum nicht
ankurbeln also wenn sie das einkommen
unserer landwirte verbessern wollen dann
sorgen sie für wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
für neue absatzwege bisher sehe und höre
ich nur das gegenteil
wer versucht die gesetze der
marktwirtschaft in offenen märkten so
wie wir sie haben auszublenden der läuft
einer fata morgana hinterher denn je
näher sie sich eben dieser vermeintliche
nur ase von staatlichen mindestpreisen
nähern um so mehr werden sie auch
hoffentlich erkennen dass das einfach
nur eine illusion der planwirtschaft ist
hören sie auf diesem phantom
nachzulaufen gehen sie stattdessen einen
weg der zum ziel führt ihr vorgänger im
amt jochen borchert hat doch mit seiner
expertenkommission einen gangbaren weg
aufgezeigt doch gerade zur borchert
kommission gibt ihr koalitionsvertrag
gar nichts er gar nichts keine und an
dieser stelle habe ich noch einmal auf
das zurückkommen was sie gesagt haben
sie haben sicher beschwert dass in der
letzten regierung hier nicht genügend
passiert ist ich will noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass beim label es sie auch
sie persönlich waren die die kritischen
fragen gestellt haben
dass die eu konformität angeht und sie
haben die frage gestellt ob es hier zu
einer notifizierung kommen kann sie
wollten durch hat umsetzen wer hat denn
gemauert man baurecht beim
emissionsrechte bei der ta luft war der
große missionswerk linie das waren sie
was sie hier veranstaltet haben
beschuldigung das war heuchlerisch
eigentlich wollte ich heute höflich
bleiben aber an der stelle muss ich
ihnen das ganz deutlich mit auf den weg
geben so können sie sich eh nicht
aufhören es ist an ihnen gescheitert
nicht an uns und deswegen bitte ich sie
noch mal herr minister mit bei aller
offenheit wirklich setzen sie sie haben
ja auch hinweise darauf gegeben setzen
sie die ideen der mordkommission um und
wir werden sie dabei konstruktiv
begleiten ja was wir alle immer wieder
erleben dass es ja häufig ein sehr
falsch dargestellte bild der
landwirtschaft gibt uns vermittelt wird
viele fehlinformationen vor allem halten
und deshalb auf einen fruchtbaren boden
weil das wissen über moderne
landwirtschaft auf dem rückzug ist
deshalb brauchen wir auch ein
agrarmarketing was einfach auch einen
hohen informationswert hat faktisch
findet heute keine verständliche
verbraucherkommunikation mehr statt und
dabei haben die bürger natürlich ein
recht darauf zu erfahren wie inland wird
oder wie die landwirtschaft in
deutschland tatsächlich und wirklich
praktiziert wird kollegin ich habe die
eu angehalten gestatten sie eine frage
oder bemerken erst können wir gerne am
ende auch wenig dass er ja teile ich und
ich sag auch gleich ich lasse also ich
würde gerne ich würde gerne im
zusammenhang vortragen und dann kann der
kollege die kollegin ihren intervenieren
gut
also um wieder zurück zum agrarmarketing
zu kommen um ihr auch einen ganz
konkreten vernünftigen konstruktiven
vorschlag zu machen wir werden schon in
der nächsten sitzungswoche science der
union hier einen antrag auf den weg
bringen und ja ich empfehle ihnen sich
diesen antrag genauer anzuschauen und
auch hier konstruktiv mit in die
beratungen zu gehen ja es gibt aber auch
weitere gründe die auf einen fehlstart
der neuen bundesregierung dem hinter den
deutschen da gibt es halt schlicht ganz
handwerkliche fehler dazu zählt zum
beispiel auch die nicht fristgerechte
einreichung des strategieplans zum
ersten januar als entschuldigung wird
von ihnen aufgeführt dass es
verzögerungen beim trilog ab diese
verzögerung haben aber
eu-mitgliedstaaten betroffenen betroffen
und trotzdem haben alle fast alle
eu-mitgliedstaaten pünktlich geliefert
deutschland nicht also unsere landwirte
brauchen dringend planungssicherheit bei
der gab und keine entschuldigung und
weitere verzögerung kümmern sie sich
darum herr minister und machen sie die
gemeinsame agrarpolitik zu ihrer
chefsache das ding ist einfach viel zu
wichtig ja meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren deutschland ist ein starker
agrarstandort nirgendwo auf der welt
gibt es so viel gesunde und sichere und
hochwertige lebensmittel wie bei uns und
die landwirtschaft dient eben nicht nur
den zielen des umwelt und des
klimaschutzes wie es uns der ampel
koalitionsvertrag weismachen will der
bundesminister wenn ich mir ihren
terminplan für diese woche so ansehe
dann handeln sie aber genau nach dieser
maxime erst einmal mit den
umweltverbänden reden und dann mit den
landwirten so beginnt bestimmt kann
neues miteinander um landwirtschaft und
gesellschaft zusammenzuführen unsere
landwirte hinlege schuldige man sie
können weiter schlecht und wundersamer
auf kosten ihres kollegen unsere
landwirten und landwirtschaft arbeiten
hart für unser tägliches brot vielleicht
leisten wichtige beiträge zum erhalt
unserer vielfältigen kulturlandschaft
und sind bedeutender wirtschaftsfaktor
und arbeitgeber im ländlichen raum
deshalb verdienen unsere bauernfamilien
respekt perspektiven und
planungssicherheit und wir wollen sie in
zukunft kritisch
dabei begleiten dass sie auch ein
würdiges bl mit einem würdigen
bundesminister bekommen dazu noch einmal
alles gute für die zukunft vielen dank
fürs zuhören ein wenig versöhnlich endet
er dann doch albert stegemann hier für
die cdu csu fraktion aber wirklich den
terminen planen dass minister scannt das
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen also wir
kennen ihn nicht allerdings kann ich
hier nochmal sagen die erwähnte borchert
kommission war in der vergangenen
legislatur hier wichtig hat nämlich
verschiedene vorschläge dazu gemacht wie
der umbau der nutztierhaltung umgesetzt
und finanziert werden könnte war noch
von julia klöckner beauftragt worden
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister zu mir erstmal von uns
auch herzlichen glückwunsch zu ihrer
ersten rede im bundestag als minister
für ernährung landwirtschaft sie hat mir
sehr gut gefallen und natürlich auch
sondern glückwunsch von den mitgliedern
des entsprechenden ausschusses und
natürlich auch von mir an sie sind sehr
große erwartungen gerichtet und wir sind
optimistisch dass der lähmende und für
viele landwirte inzwischen
existenzbedrohende zustand in dem
bereich absehbar abzuwenden ist in den
letzten acht aber besonders in den
letzten vier jahren wurden schon in
koalitionsverträgen vereinbarte team
einfach nicht entschieden vertagt oder
unter dem mantel der freiwilligen
vereinbarung verbessert oder entwertet
drohenden
vertragsverletzungsverfahren mit einem
mindestmaß an zugeständnissen
ruhiggestellt und einiges kommt gerade
es ist erwähnt wurden wieder zurück
office oder es gab erst konkrete
gesetzliche und einigermaßen
ausreichende regelung nachdem
höchstrichterlich darüber entschieden
wurde dass das
landwirtschaftsministerium
endlich umzusetzen hat alles in allem
eine sehr sehr unterdurchschnittliche
bilanz auch wenn das eben etwas anders
dargestellt worden ist und da ich nun
kenne wie sich derartige arbeitsweisen
ankündigen bin ich umso optimistischer
dass dies in zukunft nicht mehr so sein
sie müssen als minister für ernährung
und landwirtschaft daher leider nicht
nur jede menge restanten aufarbeiten
sondern auch eine fülle von themen die
jetzt dazu kommt und alles möglichst
zeitnah und mit den ersten ergebnissen
im ersten jahr das ist ein riesenpaket
und dabei wollen wir gerne mit allen uns
zur verfügung stehenden möglichkeiten
sie dabei unterstützen wir haben
wirklich als spd-fraktion lange genug
darauf gewartet dass endlich was
passiert
ich möchte hier noch mal ganz besonders
was auch schon erwähnt worden ist das
tierwohl leben das 4 wo label erwähnen
mit seiner gesamten bandbreite an
erfordernissen das ist ja schon
dargestellt wurden es ist bislang
unfreiwillig um noch mal offen stegemann
einzugehen es wahr und vollständig es
wurde blockiert und es sollte nur
freiwillig sein also wir waren noch
nicht mal ansatzweise an einer umsetzung
und darauf haben wir immer wieder
gekocht und werden dann sitzt nur ein
vollständiges label verabschiedet und
nicht ein dreiviertel schweineleben das
hatten wir öfter schon als thema hier im
bundestag
natürlich ist die zukünftige ausrichtung
nerven bewahren der landwirtschaft viel
umfassender dazu wird meine kollegin
isabel marken sind gleich noch einiges
sagen und auch den völlig bislang
unterschätzten bereich ernährung auf den
sie ja schon eingegangen sind dazu wird
meine kollegin tg schierenberg in
wenigen minuten noch was sagen der
tierschutz das möchte ich noch mal als
bisherige tierschutzbeauftragte erwähnt
hat aber ebenfalls ein enormer
aufholbedarf sei es in den bereich des
völlig unregulierten anonymisierten
online handels sei es bei heimtieren
oder exoten qualzucht leben
tiertransporte zirkus tierhaltung
tierversuche nicht kurative eingriffe
wir können noch ordentlich die liste
fortsetzen da ist nichts passiert
entscheidung wird es auch geben wie wir
die transformation und die
digitalisierung in der landwirtschaft
vorantreiben wie kann wo energie
eingespart werden bei wärme lüftung und
möglichst überall regenerative und
besonders in der landwirtschaft selbst
erzeugte energie eingesetzt werden die
kernenergie bezeuge erzeugung und
landwirtschaftliche produktion und
biodiversität vernetzt werden und nicht
immer diese debatte entweder oder die
nicht unbedingt negativen auswirkungen
vom
kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz vom
lieferketten gesetzt und von der
preisgestaltung durch steigende co2
zertifikate für deutsche produkte in
konkurrenz zu ausländischen produkten
müssen vorausschauend angegangen werden
und welche auswirkungen haben denn der
green deal die gab derzeit laufende und
absehbare europarechtliche regelung auf
ernährung und landwirtschaft hier muss
auch addiert werden und nicht immer nur
reagiert denn kurz vor fristende
und wie kann in diesem bereich gesunde
ernährung gekennzeichnet erkannt
vermittelt und gefördert werden und
immer wieder die entscheidende frage wo
kommt es wirklich her und was ist
wirklich drin wir vernetzen uns mit
anderen ressorts die arbeit und soziales
bei denen sie sorgt arbeitskräften mit
gesundheit bei ernährung mit bau und bei
stahlbau und brandschutz mit umwelt bei
emission und mit innen bei
katastrophenschutz auch tiere sind bei
katastrophen zu retten um nur einige zu
nennen es ist also jede menge
handlungsbedarf vorhanden und das nicht
zu knapp es steht viel arbeit debatte
austausch um entscheidung an aber dafür
ist uns nicht bange ich freue mich drauf
herzlichen dank
soweit die rede von susanne mittag und
der nächste redner steht ihr schon
bereit frankreich für die afg fraktion
ist dass er sitzt im ausschuss für
ernährung und landwirtschaft
wartet noch kurz bis das pult des
infiziert wurde und dass hier jetzt ist
seine erste rede im bundestag
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau präsidentin werte
kollegen die landwirtschaft steckt in
einer der schlimmsten krisen aller
zeiten nicht kostendeckende preise stark
verteuerte pachten bauern bashing
überhöhte düngerpreise und viel zu viel
bürokratie und
als landwirt kann ich ihnen sagen ich
könnte den ganzen weiteren nachmittag
noch andere dinge aufzählen zur sache
die neue bundesregierung und
federführend der kanzler hat in seiner
amtseinführung von der großen
transformationen gesprochen ich für
meinen teil kann nur hoffen dass am ende
dieser großen transformation nicht das
ende unserer heimischen landwirtschaft
steht
als im letzten jahr die globalen
lieferketten wegen des corona virus zum
erliegen kam haben wir verehrte kollegen
gesehen wie empfindlich unsere
lieferketten und unsere wirtschaft
weltweit ist und ich will mir an dieser
stelle auch gar nicht ausmalen was in
diesem land passieren würde wenn in den
läden statt klopapier es an
lebensmitteln fehlen würde das bitte ich
sie allemal zu bedenken aus diesem grund
kann ich sie nur ermahnen die landwirte
zu unterstützen ihre betriebe zu stärken
und ihnen eine vernünftige
wirtschaftliche perspektive zu bieten um
die versorgung unserer bevölkerung in
deutschland sicherzustellen
kehren sie ab vom importwaren und kommen
sie zurück zum standard made in germany
gerade bei den lebensmitteln wir werden
ihnen gern dabei helfen standards zu
schaffen die dafür sorgen dass unsere
landwirte unseren bauern hier in
deutschland gut zurechtkommen dass sie
qualitativ hochwertige und regionale
lebensmittel erzeugen können und ohne
dabei an den rand des ruins gedrängt zu
werden vernünftige pflanzen gerechte
düngung und eine angemessene
pflanzenschutz wäre ein notwendiger
baustein eben genau dafür genauso wie
planungssicherheit und garantien für
diese landwirte dass sich die
investition von heute auf morgen noch
lohnen dann muss ich sagen wir haben
vorhin einige beiträge gehört
hinsichtlich der schweinehalter und der
preise meine damen und herren leider
haben wir hier nicht zu afrikanischen
schweinepest gehört die sich hier immer
weiter ausbreitet nichtsdestotrotz gibt
es nur sporadische maßnahmen gegen diese
ausbreitung das bedroht die
schweinehalter in ganz deutschland aber
gut soviel dazu zudem weitet ihr haltern
noch einmal weiter wir hörten davon wir
wollen die stelle schöner machen aber
beginnen wir doch erst mal damit unsere
weidetiere zu schützen zu schützen vor
raubtieren wie den wölfen die beweislast
dort umzukehren bayerisch vorfällen am
besten erleichtern wir es so erklären
dass komplett um damit auch diese beide
tierhalter eine zukunft haben die sie
hier ja scheinbar gar nicht
durchsichtigen wollten
ideologie war noch nie ein guter
ratgeber und das ist auch gerade beim
thema wolf nicht artenvielfalt haben wir
hier auch heute gehört das ist natürlich
sehr interessant wenn wir raubtiere hier
züchten die im anschluss daran unsere
nutztiere auffressen frau präsidentin
ich habe das im blick ich bin auch
gleich fertig zu guter letzt noch ein
paar worte zu dem was hier bisher von
der regierung entschieden wurde was
eigentlich auch absolut negativ für die
deutschen landwirte waren die absenkung
des mehrwertsteuersatzes
der wurde von 10,7 auf 9,5 prozent
gesenkt das war ein absoluter schlag in
die handy pauschalisierenden
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe dieser
beschluss kostet die landwirte in diesem
jahr 90 millionen euro die sich die
bundesregierung schnell mal selber
eingesteckt hat vielen dank dafür an die
regierung auch von mir als landwirt ein
letzter satz dann bin ich auch fertig
herr minister was sie mir wir werden sie
an ihren taten messen
schaffen sie bessere
zukunftsperspektiven wie werden sie dann
natürlich bei unterstützen und ein
schlaues altes sprichwort vom landes
sagt lebt der bauer lebt das land vielen
dank
nächster redner für die fdp ist
karlheinz busen er ist sprecher für
forst und jagd politik in seiner für die
es um
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
herr minister auf meiner seite gute
zusammenarbeit das eine kann ich ihnen
jetzt schon sagen stolz können die seien
auf unseren wald er ist unser
wichtigstes mittel gegen den klimawandel
es gibt keine größere co2 senke in
unserem land der ungefähr 126 tonnen pro
jahr co2 speichert also damit ist die
forstwirtschaft der einzige
wirtschaftszweig der co2 bindet und
nicht imitiert und außerdem ist der wald
unser wichtigster
unser wichtigster rohstofflieferant beim
nachhaltigen bauen mit holz was allen
ampelkoalitionen wichtig ist daher
bedarf es natürlich einer guten
waldbewirtschaftung die zahlreichen
leistungen die unsere waldbesitzer noch
so erbringen honorieren werden der klima
robuste waldumbau hat also hohe
priorität von den elf millionen hektar
wald müssten ungefähr drei millionen
hektar umgebaut werden und dafür braucht
es gute rahmenbedingungen was wir nicht
brauchen sind großflächige stilllegung
von bewirtschafteten waldflächen also
stilllegung bedeute stillstand und den
darf es beim klimaschutz auch nicht
geben
wir müssen natürlich auch nicht
heimische baumarten einsetzen um uns
gegen die folgen des klimawandels zu
rüsten das hat sich auch bewährt weil
der waldumbau nicht erst heute oder
morgen beginnt den waldumbau betragen
wir schon seit 30 jahren
und nicht nur im privatwald brauchen wir
erneuerung besondere standards streben
wir auch für die wälder an die
unmittelbar im bundesbesitz sind bundes
waldflächen die direkt vom bund genutzt
werden also blieben nicht verpachtet
sind sollen nach dem fsc standards
bewirtschaftet werden nur wenn der
waldumbau gelingt bietet der wald auch
langfristig eine gute heimat für unsere
wildtiere die jagd ist gelebter natur
und artenschutz gesunde fischbestände
sind dabei das ziel und das funktioniert
auch wenn der wildtierbestand
ideologiefrei reguliert wird kaum ein
thema erhitzt die gemüter im ländlichen
raum mehr als der umgang mit den wölfen
die letzte bundesregierung hat uns beim
wolf immer wieder schöngerechnete zahlen
vorgelegt und da wollen wir jetzt genau
hinschauen wir werden die zahl der in
deutschland lebenden wölfe
realitätsgetreu abbilden
dafür brauchen wir natürlich unsere
revieren habe die sich am besten in den
revieren ausgabe die sich am besten in
den revieren auskennen alle leidet die
halter im land die diese bundesregierung
wird den ländern ein regional
differenziertes bestandsmanagement
ermöglichen liebe kollegen union
jetzt fordern sie auch den abschuss des
wolfes hätten längst erfolgen können in
meiner heimat in nrw wo ich die größten
probleme mit den wölfen gibt ist
ausgerechnet eine cdu ministerin am
werke die leider noch keine lösung
gefunden hat und ich muss als ampel wir
schaffen das
soweit die rede aus der fdp-fraktion
hier natürlich mit dem mittlerweile
geflügelten satz wir schaffen das
der ist diese woche schon mal übrigens
gefallen karl lauterbach a face in bezug
auf die korona pandemie auch schon
gesagt artur auernhammer spricht jetzt
für die unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren während der
koalitionsverhandlungen wurde ja viel
spekuliert gibt es überhaupt noch ein
eigenständiges
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium das ist
schon mal gut gelaufen denn dieses haus
ist wichtig für unser land entscheidend
ist aber auch was daraus gemacht wird
und es wurde auch viel spekuliert wer
für den minister würde ist die
geschätzte kollegin lenke er dass der
landwirtschaftsminister der herzen anton
hofreiter nein die wahl fiel auf cem
özdemir und herr bundesminister meine
gratulation zu diesem amt zu diesen sehr
wichtigen amt und sie diesen sehr
wichtigen amt auch für unser land denn
es geht in erster linie auch darum
unsere eigene bevölkerung mit heimischen
produkten mit lebensmitteln zu ernähren
das ist die wichtigste aufgabe unserer
heimischen landwirtschaft und das muss
auch in diesem haus entsprechend
honoriert werden wir haben aktuell auch
ganz große herausforderungen und da
haben sie keine 100 tage mehr zu warten
da müssen wir handeln die aktuelle
corona welle mit arne krohn ist nicht
nur eine belastung für die
gesundheitssysteme wir brauchen auch
hier antworten für unsere
lebensmittelbetriebe damit damit diese
auch im falle eines ausbruchs
weiterarbeiten können da müssen wir noch
rahmenbedingungen setzen nicht damit am
ende des tages die lebensmittelregale
leer bleiben und wir haben auch eine
ganz ganz große herausforderung bei der
bekämpfung der afrikanischen
schweinepest
unsere schweine erzeuger machen zurzeit
eine ganz bittere zeitung hier müssen
wir zusammenarbeiten mit den ländern
hier brauchen wir lösungen hier müssen
die absatzwege wieder besser werden
und ja ihre worte hören sich jetzt zu
beginn einer legislaturperiode gut an
wir werden sie in den nächsten jahren
dann auch an ihren taten messen und bei
dieser konstellation diese ampel
koalition wird es sehr interessant
allein die ausführungen der fdp kollegen
da frage ich mich sind die jetzt in
einer anderen partei gewechselt seit der
bundestagswahl
welche worte haben wir von diesen
kollegen vor der bundestagswahl gehört
welche nachrichten wurden hier
verbreitet in den sozialen netzwerken
und dann bei den koalitionsverhandlungen
haben sie die interessen der bauern
fallen lassen wie eine heiße kartoffel
sie haben keinerlei interesse an diesen
ministerien sie haben keinerlei
interesse am umweltministerium sie haben
keinerlei interesse an den
bauernfamilien
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wenn wir darüber diskutieren wir
brauchen wir höhere lebensmittelpreise
wir brauchen in erster linie bessere
erzeugerpreise bessere wertschöpfung
wertschätzung auch für unsere arbeit der
bauernfamilien und da habe ich einen
punkt der hat mich geärgert ich sage ich
ganz offen wir haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode die reform der
gemeinsamen agrarpolitik und es gab eine
initiative
gerade die kleinbäuerlichen betriebe die
betriebe die weniger flächenausstattung
haben steigert zu fördern mit den
sogenannten mitteln der kappung und der
degression und es waren genau die
landwirtschaftsminister der grünen die
ihn der agrarministerkonferenz eine
stärkere degression verhindert haben da
sieht man wie man sich dann in der
realität zeigt wir müssen auch einen
großen blick legen auf die betriebe der
kleinbäuerlichen strukturen die auch
einen großen beitrag zur artenvielfalt
und zur biodiversität leisten und herr
minister beraten sie ihre länderkollegen
ihrer partei entsprechend ich glaube das
ist auch zielführend meine sehr
verehrten damen kann es wurde auch schon
der
des themenkomplex wald erwähnt und ich
bin sehr dankbar dafür
denn
wenn wir klimaschutz aktiv betreiben
wollen brauchen wir auch einen aktiven
wald und wir müssen aber diesen wald
auch nutzen wir müssen ihnen nicht nur
schützen wir müssen auch nutzen und
deshalb brauchen wir eine weitere
intensivierung des holzbaus aber wir
brauchen nicht eine stilllegung gewählte
keine ideologische stilllegung der
wälder sondern einem weiteren umbau
einen klimagerechten umbau unserer
wälder und wenn ich noch mal zur
tierhaltung zurück kommentar es ist
vieles gesagt worden ich hoffe dass die
umsetzung der sogenannten border guard
kommission deren koalitionsvertrag nicht
berücksichtigt worden ist dann in ihrer
arbeit berücksichtigt wird es ist ein
guter ziel führen der ansatz der es
wirklich
wert ist darüber nachzudenken uni darum
zu setzen und dazu gehört auch eine
herkunftskennzeichnung wie wichtig eine
herkunftskennzeichnung ist sehen wir
gerade zum beispiel beim wein mit der
novelle des weingesetzes der verbraucher
schaut nach der herkunft seiner produkte
und deshalb bitte ich darum eine
konsequente herkunftskennzeichnung in
den lebensmittelbereich auch einzuführen
und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren gerade bei der tierhaltung steht
auch etwas im koalitionsvertrag print es
mich umtreibt das ist das thema angehen
die haltung bei milchkühen und frau
präsidentin erlauben sie mir dass ich
diesen satz noch sagen das können wir
nur lösen wenn wir mit den
bauernfamilien nach lösungen suchen und
nicht mit verboten denn hier geht es
wirklich um bäuerliche existenzen hier
geht es um kleine mittel bäuerliche
betriebe da brauchen wir antworten und
da werden wir sie kritisch begleiten und
notfalls auch kritisiert dankeschön
artur auernhammer war das und wie er ist
auch die nächste rednerin mitglied im
ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
isabel mackensen geist spricht für die
spd-fraktion vor letzte rednerin auch
der letzte redner wird von den
sozialdemokraten kommen die letzte
rednerin
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen sehr geehrter
herr minister cem özdemir allen voran
nutze ich die gelegenheit ihm herzlich
zu ihrem neuen abend als
landwirtschaftsminister zu gratulieren
sie stehen vor großen herausforderungen
denn unsere land und forstwirtschaft ist
mit drei großen krisen konfrontiert der
klimakrise der biodiversitäts krise und
der sozialen dienste auf dem bauernhof
bei der klimakrise ist die
landwirtschaft wie kein anderer
wirtschaftsbereich so direkt von den
veränderten klimabedingungen betroffen
als rheinland pfälzerin denke ich mit
schrecken an die starkregenfälle und das
anschließende hochwasser im rheinland
pfalz und nordrhein westfalen vom
letzten jahr zurück das verdeutlicht die
dynamik durch maßnahmen wie den
humusaufbau vielfältig ruft folgen oder
auch das anlegen von akku forst systemen
können unsere landwirtschaftlichen
betriebe widerstandsfähiger gegenüber
wetterextremen werden das ist aktiver
klimaschutz denn wenn unsere böden große
wassermassen speichern können sind sie
vor erosion geschützt
dran dieser wald haben dazu einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten der nächst
unser klimaschützer nummer eins aber
auch im deutschen wald werden die folgen
des klimawandels sichtbar für unsere
kommunalen und privaten waldbesitzer
innen habe ich eine klare botschaft wir
werden sie beide
erzielten waldumbau zu artenreichen und
klima residenten wäldern unterstützen
und den umbau mit der vielseitigen
nutzung von heimischem holz als
nachhaltigen rohstoff mit einer holz wie
zieh aktive verknüpfen wir bekennen uns
zur nachhaltigen forstwirtschaft
wie wollen wir sie unterstützen wir
werden zukünftig die ökosystemleistungen
des waldes honorieren es soll ein modell
vom bundesforst ministerium und
bundesumweltministerium entwickelt
werden für diese honorierung stehen
bereits im bundeshaushalt
2022 200 millionen euro zur verfügung
die zweite krise ist die
biodiversitäts krise der rückgang der
biologischen vielfalt des dramatischen
hat bereits jetzt ein ausmaß erreicht
dass die wirtschaftlichen sozialen und
kulturellen
existenzgrundlagen von uns menschen
gefährdet gemeinsam mit den
landwirtinnen und landwirten können wir
den verlust der artenvielfalt stoppen
und die biodiversität in der
agrarlandschaft wieder stärken wir
wollen die kooperativen ansätze ausbauen
und durch gezielte agrar und
umweltpolitische fördermaßnahmen anreize
schaffen der ökolandbau ist hierbei ein
wichtiger baustein und ein
entscheidendes werkzeug wir wollen 30
prozent öko landbau bis zum jahr 2030
erreichen das ist ambitioniert denn es
bedeutet wir brauchen jedes jahr zwölf
prozent mehr bio fläche das ist nur
möglich wenn wir die voraussetzung für
ein gleichgewicht iges wachstum von
angebot und nachfrage schaffen hierfür
wollen wir die bundesmittel für das
bundesprogramm ökolandbau im neuen
haushalt erhöhen und einen stärkeren
schwerpunkt in der agrarforschung legen
wir werden die zukunftsstrategie
ökologischer landbau um die gesamte bio
wertschöpfungskette erweitern die dritte
krise ist die soziale krise der
strukturwandel in der landwirtschaft
setzt sich weiter fort so ist die anzahl
der betriebe in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten enorm zurückgegangen ein
strukturwandel von zwei prozent bedeutet
dass sich nach 25 jahren die anzahl der
betriebe halbiert wir müssen schnell
handeln um diese entwicklung zu stoppen
derzeit leiten frauen etwa elf prozent
der landwirtschaftlichen betriebe
jede dritte arbeitskraft auf den
betrieben ist eine frau tendenz steigend
denn es stehen gut ausgebildete junge
frauen in den startlöchern und demnächst
die hofnachfolge anzutreten wir haben
starke frauen in der landjugend und bei
den landfrauen sie durch ehrenamtliches
engagement die ländlichen räume lebendig
machen die landwirtschaft wird die
landwirtschaft ist weiblich
und wenn ich mir halt die neue
arbeitsgruppe ernährung landwirtschaft
der spd-bundestagsfraktion anschaue dann
sehe ich geballte frauenpower leider im
gegensatz zur rechten seite des
parlaments da ist noch ein bisschen
nachholbedarf was den frauenanteil
angeht auch der weinbau ist weiblich in
der vergangenheit war die vereinbarung
branche in fester männerhand doch
heutzutage sind die frauen auf dem
vormarsch der weinbau ist mir alsfelder
mädel eine herzensangelegenheit und
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass ich
weiterhin für die weinbaupolitik
innerhalb der spd bundestagsfraktion
verantwortlich bin und auf dem
parlamentarischen weinforum weiter
angehören darf sehr geehrte damen und
herren landwirtschaft und umweltschutz
sind keine gegensätze sondern gehörten
zusammen die zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft hat gezeigt wie solche
vermeintlichen gegensätze überwunden
werden können und wozu die nächste
generation fähig ist denn es waren die
vorsitzenden der landjugend und der bnd
jugend die eine gemeinsame
zukunftsvision für die landwirtschaft
entworfen haben sie haben uns gezeigt
wie wichtig der gemeinsame dialog und
der austausch unterschiedlicher
perspektiven sind das wollen wir
fortführen
isabel müssen geis hat hier noch mal
natürlich auf den weinbau
verwiesen das war ja auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode hat dort die ehemalige
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
aus manchmal auch häufiger hingewiesen
perry schierenbeck spd fraktion hat
jetzt hier auch ihre erste rede im
bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte minister letzte mir sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren es erfüllt mich mit großer freude
heute hier mit meiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag das thema über das
wichtige thema ernährung strategie
sprechen zu dürfen es wird zeit dass wir
etwas tun das haben wir heute schon
gehört und das haben wir sehr oft gehört
darum wird es zeit dass wir endlich
handeln
wenn es um einige sondern nachhaltige
ernährung geht werden die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in
deutschland bisher viel zu wenig
unterstützt andere länder sind da
wesentlich weiter so haben die briten
verbindliche salz reduktionsziele damit
hat sich seit 2005 das bevölkerungs
risiko für schlaganfälle und
herzerkrankungen um 40 prozent reduziert
lassen sie sich das auf der zunge
zergehen um 40 prozent reduziert ein
sieg für die gesundheit eine entlastung
für das gesundheitssystem mit einer
verpflichtenden selbst reduktion salz
reduktion im gesetz so einfach kann das
sein
mit einer zuckersteuer bzw einer abgabe
für die hersteller bode in england der
zuckergehalt in süßigkeiten reduziert
finnland frankreich spanien italien und
österreich haben feste zucker fett und
salz reduktionsziele beschränkungen für
ein kindergerichte gerichtete werbung
für süßwaren limonaden und knabbereien
gibt es bereits in dänemark frankreich
spanien norwegen schweden und slowenien
wir haben damals das jodsalz mit einer
passenden kampagne eingeführt damit
konnte man dem in der bevölkerung
festgestellt rothwangl erfolgreich
entgegenwirken oder denken sie an die
gesüßten tee es die früher babys gegeben
wurden und das darauf die ersten zähne
bevor sie überhaupt den weg durch
zahnfleisch gefunden haben oft schon
gezogen werden mussten heute ist das
unvorstellbar
mit der entwicklung einer umfassenden
ernährungs strategie für die hier heute
spreche und die wir auch im
koalitionsvertrag beschlossen haben
darüber bin ich sehr froh
wollen wir das ändern und die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
unterstützen und schützen entsprechend
den empfehlungen aus dem gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen beirats für
agrarpolitik ernährung und
gesundheitlichen verbraucherschutz aus
dem jahr 2020 muss ziel dieser
strategie seien entlang der gesamten
wertschöpfungskette von der erzeugung
über verarbeitung und handel bis hin zum
essen unsere gesundheit zu schützen
soziale mindeststandards einzuhalten
unsere umwelt und unser klima zu
schützen und das tierwohl zu erhöhen
jede strategien ist in enger
zusammenarbeit mit im
gesundheitsministerium dem
umweltministerium aber auf dem arbeits
und sozialministerium erarbeitet werden
eine ausgewogene ernährung für alle ist
die basis für gesundheit und
chancengleichheit und damit auch eine
soziale frage
insbesondere bei kindern denn gesunde
kinder haben einen besseren start ins
leben schluss mit zu süßen limonaden
schluss mit zu fertigen und salzigen
knabbereien schluss mit werbung für
ungesunde produkte die sich direkt an
kinder richtet eine nachhaltige und
ausgewogene verpflegung in kitas und
schulen ist die wirksamste maßnahme
gegen ernährungs armut und
ernährungsbedingte krankheiten eine
bessere kennzeichnung damit
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher auf den
ersten blick erkennen können welches
produkt gesünder ist auf initiative der
spd gibt es seit 2020 den nutrias chor
der zum erfolgsmodell geworden ist und
dem sich erfreulicherweise immer mehr
unternehmen freiwillig anschließen
doch leider ist er eben freiwillig eine
verpflichtende einführung kann nur über
die uhr verfolgen und dafür setzen wir
uns ein
höchst brauchen eine bessere
kennzeichnung auch für nachhaltigkeit
schluss mit dem label dschungel und
undurchsichtigen kriterien
wir wollen die ernährung politik aktiv
gestalten eine gesunde und nachhaltige
ernährungsweise erleichtern und das
politikfeld ernährung insgesamt
aufwerten wir wollen ein
ernährungspolitik die ernährung
gesundheit umwelt und soziales zusammen
denkt mit dem wissen was wir heute haben
nicht zu handeln halte ich für
fahrlässig
vielen dank weitere wortmeldungen zu
diesen themenbereichen liegen mir nicht
vor